hello welcome back to it's steals the
game where you're in a maze and
something else is in there with you and
it's all fun the next mode we're going
to be playing is living halls I don't
like the sound of that because that
could mean that the holes are actually
alive I wouldn't put it past this game
its name is legs
when in sight they don't bite pointed
toward weight
are you what
your time
volts where
what do you mean
what does this mean what is this some
scps thing it is like 087b
it's like 087b where you're sending me
down into the bottom
who's on my wrist
oh my God I did not get the prompt
I
I did not get the prompt what am I doing
oh my God the Halls are alive I don't
remember what I'm supposed to do
I guess I'm gonna find out a lesser man
or a coward would uh back out of the
game and try to read the instructions
again
I'm not going to do that what is that
what is that
what is that
oh
Lexi and make sure the instructions were
blurred for everyone else so that we're
all on the same page and we don't know
what we're doing but we're going into a
vault
Vault C specifically
so I think the thing on my wrist must be
a sensor of some kind
that's detecting either one
something good is near something bad
that's bad that's bad that's bad that's
bad it's bad it's bad
it's good
it's bad
static bad okay
duly noted static bad
I'm I'm dead 18 are you kidding me I'm
dead
I'm dead I'm dead
okay maybe not
more static
oh boy
what does a red mean
oh no
I don't know
dead I'm dead
oh I'm dead oh it's gone oh it's gone
foreign
[Music]
I'm sorry keep us in sight
did you say something about keeping us
in sight why would I need to keep you in
sight why would I keep you in sight
Insight is not what I would like to keep
you as let's try that again see if I can
get some more instructions this time
hold space oh oh that is crucial point
it towards uncertain corners or to use
the radar interesting
I don't know what that means
uncertain Corners eh all right
so uh
oh yeah oh that's not good
what do you mean uncertain corners
huh interesting
what is that this is good or bad
oh God that's not good
uh so would you call not good
[Applause]
I don't know what that means
but I think when the time runs out I'm
dead so uh yeah probably not good
don't know I I haven't the foggiest
I have no idea
it's probably just a countdown until
that thing starts coming after me I
guess
and in doing so
I don't know maybe it could give me an
idea of how to get away from it when
[Applause]
[Music]
was jiggly oh so oh
[Applause]
it's wibbly
whoo
oh frick
oh frick
I don't know what to do I I don't know
I'm the foggiest
oh
[Music]
let us get near oh well I was trying not
to new guide unlocked yeah I might need
a guide for this one they hide around
corners and freeze when they're in sight
running is risky be cautious when the
device alerts you to their presence use
the three vaults to gain extra time the
radar is essential and shows their
locations when the clock hits zero hide
in a vault and wait for the clock to
restart
ah I get it I get it so they hide around
corners and I have to be absolutely sure
that I'm not gonna go around the corner
into them that that needed explanation
so far so good
oh
[Applause]
what's with the light
I don't know
not good so what does it mean by corners
what does it mean by Corners I don't
know what it means by corners
foreign
but it seems like the layout is static
I've been going around the same
directions and it's been relatively okay
[Applause]
but I still haven't found a vault okay
down there probably oh
that's not good
is good is this okay it's okay I gotta
get to a vault quick
[Applause]
okay I gotta get to a vault that's not
good I don't know where a vault would be
oh God okay gotta get there
oh I'm screwed oh I'm screwed
oh I'm screwed
oh God
well I don't know where I am oh that's
not good oh over there oh frick I'm just
gonna go for it I'm gonna gun it I'm
gonna gun it I'm gonna gun it I'm gonna
gun it I'm gonna gun it I'm gonna gun it
I'm gunning it I'm gunning it I'm
gunning it where is it where is it oh I
saw the light where is it
I mean
I'm in
ah did I have to press a button or
something did I have to I think I
probably have right I had to press a
button okay well all right so I'm gonna
be a big Brave boy and I'm gonna uh I'm
gonna be better about whoa this is a
different one
when your time Runs Out The Vault is
your only hope oh that's more
instructions Vault hey oh good
could have used this a while ago why was
I involved oh it's a map
that's handy don't show me where
anything else is though all right I'm
brave
I'm brave I'm big and brave okay cool
here we go
oh
[Applause]
my God
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
easy bub
whoa whoa whoa
oh God I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead
oh freak why am I dead
oh my God
keep I don't know if I should keep you
inside because honestly I I think maybe
it'll be keeping you inside got me
killed oh well B ooh
point the sensor and uh and if danger is
ahead okay
use the radar to find your home
okay yes this is all extremely handy
thank you for this but I figured this
out already
right next to a vault but not next to
any crystals or whatever they are orbs
things things I need
wait did this just go in the circle wait
a minute
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] go in a circle oh no I'm not
near the vault I'm nowhere near the
Vault I'm not even close to the vault
oh come on
go away that's not good I need to go
that way because that's where the vault
is
you in that corner where are you
oh God I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead
I need to get to the phone oh my god oh
it only injured me okay I need to get to
the Vault where's the Vault The Vault
was over here I know the vault's here
oh frick where's the Vault where's the
Vault oh frick my sense of direction is
failing me my sense of direction is
failing me I'm failed I've been failed
hit hit
holy crap I made it
oh my God I made it wow okay
let's do this come out and become a part
of the maze
[Music]
I thought that it was a I thought that I
was supposed to
wasn't I supposed to
maybe running was a bad idea maybe using
all the running but maybe I should have
waited longer I guess
I think looking at it and it's saying
come out is probably not the best idea
[Applause]
oh where is that one
I should not run I should not run
what's up
so far so good
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
shelter soon
there's part of it
oh
I'm okay
oh that's not good oh freak
I'm gonna grab this
[Music]
okay where's this where's the vault
good
we're okay
wait where's the Vault oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that way
where's the button there's the button oh
okay it's time
[Music]
oh God okay so I'm assuming just that
vault is now dead and I can't go back
there which is fine
which means that I got one more chance
to get into a vault and then I'm done
no thank you
[Applause]
what
no Radar really
no radar it didn't let me turn on my
radar
oh God
[Applause]
oh my God okay no
not that way
foreign
[Applause]
not a clue where
the room would be which I gotta start
finding soon
[Applause]
oh that's not good wait wait wait
what is it oh I don't know
foreign
there's an arrow on the ground over here
might actually lead somewhere who knows
oh God that's not good
that's not good this is not good
I think I might be going back to the
first Vault that I started in when I
started this game mode
which is good
I gotta go
I gotta go Gotta Go Now gotta make it
now yes yes yes yes yes
okay that's good
um
so I just gotta really gun it for the
last few but I might have this
oh that's weird that ain't right no
[Music]
okay here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
okay not good
I'm gonna make it work we're gonna make
it work
we're gonna make it work only a few left
[Applause]
oh shoo my God
[Applause]
what was that about weirdo
holy [ __ ] okay they're real nearby the
the gems I mean
they're all in this general area four
left I can do this
oh I saw that oh my God I saw that okay
[Music]
now oh my God
no no no no
oh my God
oh
the living maze
it makes sense now
The Phantom
[Music]
you have a good premonition stay quiet I
can't see you either
press space to hold your breath click to
place a device
okay what do you mean
oh that's not good
so much to knock around
oh no
oh
foreign
I hate everything about this mode
thank you
oh my God
there's ah
God
oh my God
oh my God this is awful
foreign
[Music]
almost halfway
thank you
okay I'm recording something
foreign
[Music]
okay so that was going well I almost had
that until I didn't so I'm going to try
that again
and this time it's going to work
wonderfully no one's going to interrupt
also I don't think that the device was
terribly effective but I was in a bit of
a tizzy
foreign
[Music]
once it knows you it gets you okay good
to know oh
oh no I don't need a guide
who needs a guide
oh whoops that's not I meant to knock on
the door and I didn't oh God
oh goodness how gracious
[Music]
what does it mean does it always make
noise once the device gets placed down
is that a good thing
foreign
I feel like I completely wasted one of
my devices but I don't really know how
effective they are anyway
I don't even really hear my breath why
would I need to hold it
I feel like this is exactly where I died
before that's a familiar lamp
foreign
lesson learned
I survive
what the crap
oh it's still going on
oh what in the hacking hell
well see if there's any okay hold your
breath to avoid detection it will pass
through you if you don't make a sound oh
it will pass through me
good listen for any shifting of
furniture in another room you may only
have second stack before it finds you
when it finds you the devices are your
only defense the device will shock the
Phantom out of a Chase place them early
as they take time to charge
oh
I run it through
oh got it
I'm in it I'm on it I'm in it I'm in it
and I'm on it
so I need to run through a spot so I
should place these in thoroughfares that
I well damn it
so it's not a noisemaker
it's a do nothing
foreign
[Music]
I'm slapping another one down
never mind no I'm not apparently can
only have one down at a time
which is news
13.
12.
10 okay that's good
oh no why no no no no no I don't know
where it is I don't know where it is oh
there it is oh please no not like this
[Applause]
oh my God
[ __ ]
foreign
that seems excessively unfair why would
you do that
oh my God where are the others three
more I don't have another Lifeline this
is it like this is all I got
it
foreign
[Music]
keep wanting to come back this way
probably because I'm a noisy bastard
all right
okay they're all that way but I think I
got around this corner go left oh God no
not again
oh frick me no not like this oh I don't
know where they are I don't know where
they are I'm never gonna get them oh boy
I'm done I'm done so I'm done in rings
I'm dead I'm Million Dead I'm dead oh
frick
man that didn't that that didn't go
quite to plan
[Applause]
[Music]
left
was everything red are things lightly
red
that's weird
oh God that's not what you want to see
okay well I'm in trouble
that's exactly what I didn't want and
somehow it happened oh well
uh really are you y'all you're joking me
I have no idea where it is I have no
idea oh and that's not good oh God
oh all right so I got a bit of bad luck
there but it's okay it's all right I
just gotta stay nice and quiet and be
better about holding my breath sometimes
it does want to Circle back I think that
trying to release my breath is just
going to get me killed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
how is that even possible
feels so cheating anyway probably not
cheaty but it feels cheaty
[Applause]
what the hell
oh I guess if there's nothing in the
hallway of course there's nothing to
make any sound that makes complete sense
I guess so therefore he could just be
coming around
and you wouldn't know unless there was
stuff to be there
huh
this is impossible
Oh see it's impossible once once he
starts going through fast enough there
starts to be less and less actual stuff
to get like for him to run into and then
it just becomes quickly impossible and
then he catches up to you eventually and
then you
so I gotta be less slow about it I think
that's just like I gotta get going
foreign
[Music]
this way buddy
excellent excellent that is something
God damn it
huh seven but I don't think I'm doing
well
oh come on how is that even a thing
oh I don't remember where it is I don't
remember where it is I don't remember
where it is I can't hear where it is
there it is
okay oh my God I'm just gonna gun it I'm
just gonna gun it I can't do anything
else but gun it I've got five left I'm
gonna run out I know
three
three
two
I don't know where the last two are
there's one
[Music]
go away please
die
oh my God
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
there it is okay oh
holy [ __ ] don't stop Don't Look Back uh
no need to tell me twice Don't Stop
Don't Look Back you got it buddy oh [ __ ]
I look back oh God
oh god
oh no no no no please please I Don't
Wanna Die I Don't Wanna Die let me out I
Don't Wanna Die oh my God oh my God
please get out of the way Captain's
grandfather clocks go
oh man okay all right this is a little
much oh boy oh boy no
the end
I win I'm the best I did it I don't
think I did it but I did something so
that was it steals
except for the hard modes which there
definitely are
because they're right there there and
there so
what a lovely game that really was that
was terrifying something about just
being pursued like I said being pursued
really well is a difficult thing to do
apparently because I had to hearken back
to Slender the Eight Pages to really
capture oh yeah being pursued kind of
sucks and this one is just all about it
where Lex is pursuing you non-stop but
it's good
and I like it I think so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below more scary games in the
description on my channel thousands of
them oh and do check out distractible if
you haven't already you are going to
love it it's Bob Wade and I having a
good time doing our best to make you
laugh Link in the description check it
out if you haven't you won't regret it
guaranteed thank you and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
foreign